Gail Davis was at the concert when the
shooting started she joins us now from
Las Vegas Gail I can't imagine how you
were feeling at this second I'm so glad
that you can join us right now what can
you tell us about what you saw what
happened
oh well it's kind of just shocking but
you know you don't expect something like
this we went there to see Jason Aldean
really it was a three-day show and we
went there to see Jason he's my favorite
singer and we got there and we were
standing like maybe halfway up and I'm
just waiting for him come onstage he
came on and about 20 to 10 and we were
just listening to me saying about five
songs and all of a sudden we just heard
like three or four little pop pop pop
and everybody kind of looked around and
said oh it's just firecrackers and then
we heard pop pop pop and he just kept
going and going and my husband said
that's not quite our crackers that
sounds I could semiotic rifle and then
everybody started screaming and started
to run and I looked over to my right
where this girl had been standing right
beside me and she had fallen in wish
first she stood there and she grabbed
her stomach and she looked at her hands
her hands are all bloody and then she's
wearing like a little crop top and you
know blue jean shorts and cowboy boots
and she looked at her hands her hands
are bloody and she just kind of screamed
and she just fell back and then
everybody started yelling and there some
guys there and we just started jumping
up down like waiting for help help
and then all of a sudden we just heard a
whole bunch of shots fired and people
started running and so my husband said
kitty I'm getting on so he bent down and
everybody's just running just straight
up and you could see people getting shot
and people falling and then my husband
said Gail we got to go we got to go we
got to get out of here we're gonna get
shot and so we started running and there
was the little I don't know where the
concession stands are and little cubicle
kind of things of tents
and we started to run in a metro officer
who I owe my life to crowd does and he
said come here come here get in here get
in here so we went running inside and
the lights are on and everything else
was dark they turned the stage lights
off and everything and we went running
in there and he said kiddy out and so we
got down and I was there my husband was
in front of me and there was another two
ladies behind us and the officer
actually covered me uh to protect me
from being shot because I couldn't get
out all the way and it was like you
could hear the shots just like going
back and forth and ricocheting and it
and then they would stop and then we
thought okay it's over it's over and
then it would start again and this
happened a couple times in the officer
stood up and I heard on his radio say we
have active shooters and he heard him
say oh god and then he walked out to
look around and he had his gun out and
he was looking around and I didn't start
shooting again and he came running back
in and and covered me up again and then
it this it the shooting just would stop
like they were really or she whoever was
refilling or whatever you call it
reloading and then he said we need to
get out of here and we got to get you
out of here so he went to another little
tent and stood in there or we laid down
in there and again that officer was with
me he never he's like my guardian angel
he never left me and we could hear the
shots getting closer it's Dean and my
husband got hit like with some shrapnel
and he goes Kel I got I think I got some
some of it I don't what you call it LED
or something and he goes feel how hot it
is and he put it on my arm and we kind
of waited and then the it's the student
kind of stopped because it kept stopping
like they were refilling or something or
reloading and so then the officer said
we need to get you out of here you got
to get out here but stay low so we went
to get out the back and we couldn't get
out because there was like add or
something so we pushed it down he pushed
it down first and we ran out
said stay out of the light just run just
run and keep down keep down and as we're
running there's people laying everywhere
people were bleeding one guy was holding
his the girlfriend or wife or I don't
woman and he was crying and saying oh
god baby I'm so sorry I'm so sorry it's
my fault and I think she's been shot in
the head because he was just covered
with blood and and we ran we ran and
there was just ambulances and police
cars everywhere it was killed you were
us being real you are painting an
incredible story I am so sorry we're all
sorry that you had to go through
something like this it sounds absolutely
terrifying how long did this shooting
seem to last to you well it seemed like
a long time but maybe only 10 minutes it
seemed you know maybe 15 minutes it just
it seemed forever but then again it was
like so fast it's your mind plays tricks
on you and it's hard to say but it was
most I've never been that scared in my
life
kill how many people were in the area
where you were watching oh it was packed
it was packed because you know Jason
Aldean is just like the number one
singer and and everybody was the last
singer for the venue and for the show
and so everybody was there having a good
time it was packed
I don't know thousands it was just
packed you know everywhere Gil where's
the the officer who helped you where do
you know where he he is now no I saw his
face and I I'm gonna try to go down to
Metro and see if I can find him
and look at his pictures because he he
saved me I know because you know I just
the girl that got shot was right next to
me I don't know I wish I can find him
I'm gonna try to find him and some thank
you of course that that police is
amazing that police officer like you
said a guardian angel for you and your
husband there can you describe the rest
of the scene though in terms of security
how quickly did you see first responders
run towards the scene and start helping
the wounded almost immediately
Metro is there the
they're always right there you know
their match has such an amazing police
force and they were right there
ambulances were coming we had ambulances
everywhere of their police cars
everywhere and the police officers were
helping the other concert goers were
helping everybody it was just amazing we
all came together and everybody was
helping everybody it was it was
wonderful to see and I just love Metro
I'm just so proud of them yeah a lot of
people are giving big kudos to the Las
Vegas police department it would not
apparently have made a difference in
this particular shooting but did you
have to go through any sort of security
device when you went into the concert
today
no yeah when you walk through they look
at you you know I didn't have anything
because I you know I don't care anything
I know my job stupid no no they they'll
look at your backpacks and stuff but it
was secure it's very secure and my
husband saw the shots from Mandalay Bay
they were like a little bit above
halfway a little bit higher up and he
could actually see like lights flashing
like like and then they said that yeah
he saw this the doesn't where the
shooter was yeah you know yeah I can
tell and I know this is traumatic I'm
sure that you were still in quite a bit
of shock but have you been able to wrap
your brain around that you went to a
Jason Aldean concert of all things and
this happened to you this seems like a
terrible movie I know I know I mean I
saw Jason San Bernadino last year and
you know he's just amazing and my
husband kind of surprised me and because
we didn't know the first two days and
then he said well let's go see Jason in
he got his tickets and the little
wristbands you know and it was a
wonderful surprise and to have this
happen you know it's I just I just can't
wrap my mind around it like you see it
in Jason Jason posted a Facebook message
to all of those fans like yourself who
were there to see him and we spoke with
another performer who was on stage right
before him Jay Cohen who said that he
had seen children in the crowds as well
sitting on their parents shoulders did
you get a sense of
many children were at the concert we
know it was around 10 p.m. but but
clearly there are music fans in all ages
and parents do bring them to these kind
of concerts yeah
Jason's just a great all-around singer
and he's such a good guy and you know he
has two daughters himself and you know
Britney's his wife expecting a baby in a
couple months and everybody he's so
wholesome everybody loves him and there
were kids there and I remember one lady
was just screaming and she's going I
can't find my daughter I can't find my
daughter cuz and I don't know if she
found her she made it or anything it
just it was just like chaos
it was just crazy you know Gail when we
talked to Jay Cohen earlier today he
said that he hopes that people will
still continue that he's going to get
back on stage and perform he hopes that
anyone who was at the concert will
continue to do so that we won't let a
coward as he says change our way of life
how are you feeling about that oh no I
know I I'll still go of course I'll go I
think I'll be a little more on guard but
you can't foresee something like this
you can't expect this but no you know
I'll go again I'm sure we all love all
our country artists we're all going to
go again we support and we love them
Jason well Gayle Gayle that police
officer was a here and it sounds like
your husband was a hero as well for
having a peace of mind to recognize
those weren't firecrackers that they
were in fact gunshots we wish of the
best of his recovery from the shrapnel
wounds Gail thank you so much thank you
thank you appreciate it